gents Aviano admits she's in love with
new bachelor nick vile we all know nick
is going to be the next Bachelor
but we're still watching his
relationship with Jen play out on
bachelor in paradise and on night one of
the finale Jen dropped the L bomb on us
ahead of her steamy overnight date with
Nick I'm in love with me
but Nick didn't seem to be feeling it as
much I do love Jen as a person I know
that I just I'm not sure if I'm in love
yeah et's lauren zima spoke to jen ahead
of the finale where she opened up about
being uncertain about her future with
Nick would you want him to propose
tomorrow I wouldn't want him to propose
tomorrow no we're just not there yet
I did come in in the middle of this our
relationship is moving at a very normal
pace I'm very happy with where we're at
it's just I don't know if it's enough
right now certainly not enough for an
engagement he's had a guard up this
whole time has been on the show twice
and he got burned twice and so I think
that's definitely on his mind
meanwhile grant and lace are sure about
their feelings and making them permanent
think I mean it's gonna last forever
I want Lacey my to last forever so many
feels we can't wait to see what goes
down on night 2 let us know what couples
you think will be getting engaged over
on twitter at ET now
you